bonjour est ce que vous savez comment
est-ce qu'on tue un français non je ne
sais pas bien il suffit bêtement du tir
et 10 cm au dessus de la tête et
pourquoi comme ça voulu tuer son
complexe de supériorité
vous savez pourquoi le lion à waterloo
et roulait vraiment vite et je tiens pas
non pour montrer son coup franc c'est
[Musique]
est ce que vous savez pourquoi il n'a
pas de ker h sur l'autoroute
mais parce que les françaises prennent
tous pour des lumières
c'est beaucoup les français ils tournent
autour de l'école en courant
ils poursuivent leurs études c'est
pourquoi des français est toujours des
nôtres 0 à l'école
parce qu'il ya tant d'autres plus basse
[Musique]